Uh,
let me,
uh,
give a forward view of today in relationship to the week afterward.
Uh,
today we have Jim Alexander on Enron,
and we'll do this as a conversation except that at a certain point he's,
he's gonna just do a little straight lecturing on some basics.
It too unfamiliar ideas in the HBS case or potentially unfamiliar ideas.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
a,
the Enron case is arguably the most important meltdown in the modern history of
American capitalism.
It is certainly the one which has rebutted the world's attention more than any
other.
And Jim was there,
uh,
at the beginning or not at the beginning,
but they're in a,
it,
uh,
an almost perfect vantage point.
Um,
so we're
fortunate to have him today.
Before I go further,
I should say it's his birthday.
Yeah.
He,
I think does want me to tell you which one it is.
And
there we go.
Um,
on Monday we'll have Richard Madely,
a founder of a medley global advisors.
Uh,
and that case is about his chalet medleys selling medley global advisors and
quitting.
And the question is,
how could it,
how could a business have tens of millions of dollars worth of value when it is
entirely framed around the personality of one person?
And the answer is she got it done and he will be a very interesting,
uh,
gassed.
He's completely unpredictable.
Um,
and he is famous or infamous or George Soros attack on the pound.
Sterling.
Uh,
this was nearly 20 years ago when a Soros famous hedge fund,
uh,
decided it was going to attack the pound sterling and
Richard Medley was then working for Soros and medley had inside information
about the behavior of the central banks of continental Europe was able to
predict their behavior,
sort of Soros,
the Soros Fun,
uh,
made well over a billion dollars on one transaction in an attack on the value of
the pound,
which was an,
and the attack was controversial and medleys rolling and controversial.
And we'll have some fun with him about that.
Uh,
you should begin now reading poster.
The pages are small.
Uh,
but it's a,
it's a,
it's a dense book.
It's,
it's a challenging book and you'll need it for Wednesday of next week when we
have,
we'll get spun in as a guest.
A will is,
uh,
the director of the Yale International Center for finance,
and like Jim,
a Yale college alum and uh,
uh,
something again,
like Jim,
something of a renaissance man.
Uh,
but he's going to be talking about the crash of Oh eight,
which is a pretty intricate story.
And the Posner is
easily the best book written about it though,
not easily the easiest book written about.
So without further ado,
a gym is a 1973 graduate of Yale College.
And let's,
let's talk to them about your life after yoke.
There is life after Yale college and how it began for you and how it carried
forward until the date you arrived at Enron.
I'll shorten the version and this other,
the details get to be sort of tedious.
Uh,
um,
let's see.
Okay,
well anyway,
I went to HBS because all the smart people,
we're going into law or medicine.
I had a primitive sense of markets and I knew that I should avoid,
uh,
the smart people much as I did in my classes.
And,
um,
I then from HBS went to Aetna life and casualty,
investing their money on investment department to my then wife announced either
weaken,
leave Hartford or she could leap Hartford.
Uh,
at which point I sort of started searching for a job in New York and landed one
at a venerable old firm called Kuhn Loeb and company may mate rest in peace,
um,
which promptly merged out of existence about nine months after I joined it.
And,
uh,
at the time I emerged the Lehman Brothers at the time I listened to my uncle who
was a client of Lehman and avoided Lehman.
Um,
I went to work at first Boston,
another may it rest in peace,
actually sort of firm and um,
um,
then,
and an astonishing move of true idiocy.
I went back to Lehman in 1981 and the industry department,
cause I was interested in energy,
uh,
until uh,
sheriffs in acquired Lehman.
And it had all the human characteristics of Lehman,
the economic characteristics of Shearson.
I you the worst of both worlds.
Um,
and then I being that the flying Dutchman,
a finance went to Drexel to live when puff.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it went broke in 1990.
Um,
and,
um,
I then,
uh,
I had one last job and conventional investment banking with a New Orleans from
to the head of the firm announced I had a quote on economic attachment to
quality unquote,
which was about the worst thing you could say about anyone.
So I took my quixotic approach and became a consultant,
um,
uh,
charging sort of minimum wage by investment banking,
standards and maximum wage by college professors.
Okay.
I don't,
I don't know,
uh,
economic college professors standards.
So it's not,
uh,
but,
um,
I think Steve Ross makes a lot of money,
but it doesn't make it here or an MIT hello.
That's a separate issue.
But anyway,
um,
so I was,
uh,
one of my past clients and I was there actually at the start of Enron cause I
was there.
Uh,
we help refinance and Ron's huge amounts of,
of,
of death that we're about to go into default unless we had done something when
they,
when the Enron was created in 1984 or five,
uh,
85,
I think.
Um,
and,
um,
one of my clients have been Enron.
I became a,
uh,
an investment bank.
It conventional investment banking.
I became a consultant then Ron sorta working on,
uh,
their,
attempt to roll up their aggregate into one into one
legal entity.
Uh,
all of their,
uh,
foreign projects.
Um,
and,
uh,
after a while,
the complexities were such that virtually no one had the institutional memory
required to be able to complete the deal except for one or two people.
Uh,
and,
um,
uh,
they needed someone who knew what they knew that story to be able to,
to really stay on with the company.
And they asked me if I wanted to do that and I ended up,
uh,
a greening,
and,
uh,
then I was there a full nine months until this was a 1994.
A four,
is there about nine months before I,
the general counsel and the controller all resigned and the fall of 1995 you
spend those nine months,
all of them I think as chief financial officer of Enron global pipeline and
power.
Yes.
I was um,
those nine months were spent at the subsidiary level as the CFO of this one
little a subsidiary company of theirs.
But during that time,
mmm.
Anyone who walked the halls of Enron good pick up lots of information and the
only issue is whether you wanted to ignore it or not.
And of course a lot of people's uh Huh.
Excellent livelihoods dependent,
dependent on,
they're ignoring the information freely available in the halls.
Uh,
which turned out generally to be quite accurate.
Was the ethical texture Enron a noticeably different from the general mine run
of investment banking as you,
it?
Well that's an excellent question.
The problem is there a,
you can either trace Tracy declining curve,
constantly declining curve and investment banking from the time I entered
investment banking in 1975 or postulate a somewhat easier or sort of old style
investment backing and new style.
Um,
and the old style really was a gentleman's game.
I'm not talking about pre sec,
pre 1929 crash,
but certainly when I entered there was an old generation that was um,
um,
quite ethical,
upright and gentlemanly.
Uh,
and of course those people died out or were pushed off the edge and uh,
were replaced by people who have like different ilk and which were,
who were much more like Enron.
But for like Enron,
Enron is a very young entity and grew up in the period after the fall,
so to speak.
What do you want them off the hook a little about that or not and run off the
hook.
Yeah.
And buy,
I don't think you will by saying how would I let them off the hook by the way,
you know,
they,
they were brought up by wolves and therefore behave like walls there.
Well,
if you,
if you are a wolf,
you are typically brought up by wolves.
But,
um,
uh,
the,
one of the things is I've been listening to your course,
all the lectures and looking at the readings.
One of the things that I've been trying to piece in my own mind together,
uh,
is,
is what went wrong.
When did,
in the course of development of the theory of capitalism did,
uh,
the theoreticians decided there was no need for morality.
Uh,
and uh,
when did,
when did morality,
it replaced by efficiency.
Um,
and um,
you know,
at Enron it,
um,
it would be a
situation where,
uh,
the,
ethical extremes,
the ethical environment was so a completely different,
uh,
that it begs the question of,
of,
of what is morality and,
uh,
and what do we base it on?
Uh,
because,
uh,
the people that work there would find any concepts
of morality laughable and merely a trap for the unwary.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Stating the case has lots of lots of jargon in it that is business speak and
Leslie huff and some others have suggested that it might be useful to go through
some of that.
Okay.
Some of that background language before we do the case.
And I'm going to descend to the audience and take you in the lecture lecture.
Well,
well,
we're lecture lap.
Um,
well Enron,
um,
like a number of other firms got very involved in,
in commodities and commodity financing and commodity contracts.
And um,
if you're the typical commodity small producer,
oftentimes over leveraged,
you know,
hand to mouth existence really can't take a big plying leap and then hope to
make a lot of money.
What you typically start to do is in the case of an oil and gas producer,
let's say gas producer in particular,
I have a general view as to what I'm going to produce each month and I,
and this,
these are prices,
not production amounts,
but I have a general idea what I'm gonna Produce.
The January,
February,
on and on,
it's very hard to shut down a gas.
Well you don't,
it's typically not really,
uh,
done.
Uh,
you typically just produce flat out and then try to do the best you can with
your price realizations.
But I know I'm going to be producing a certain amount and the first question is,
okay,
do I take a flyer or not?
Most people who have a lot of debt or squeezed for other reasons don't take a
flyer.
So what they do is they can go to a commodities broker and say,
what price will you give me for each month for the rest of the year?
And,
um,
the typic end or else they can go to a commodities exchange and get the same
result.
But what they do is they will say,
okay,
I'll sell you the equivalent of a thousand barrels of oil and gas terms about,
um,
in,
in January four,
$5 equivalent of price in February.
It'll be slightly declining in,
in spring,
uh,
as a result of expected,
a lack of demand for gas,
then start to middle level out in summer,
and then we'll start going up.
So the,
so the commodities broker will commit to buy a certain amount each month.
Now,
if you're the producer though,
there's only one problem you don't,
you expect to be able to produce.
But what if something goes wrong with your well?
Well,
if something goes wrong with you,
well you're committed to sell each month.
Okay?
So what oftentimes will happen is that instead of actually committing to sell a
certain amount each month,
that producer will buy a a put.
So that in case the price does go down,
he can make money,
but he's not obligated to sell a certain volume.
So will you start doing is having very many very variations on a theme of
helping producers and consumers were on the other side who also want to hedge.
They want to determine their costs of good sold.
You started having very many types of of of mechanism contractual mechanisms to
allow producers to fix to varying extents the likelihood of certain outcomes for
their firm for the year.
And they get hugely complex.
This is just just the start.
There are huge numbers of variations on a theme.
Ways that you can lock in certain types of spreads,
ways that you can hedge all sorts of variables beyond just the,
the pricing in south Louisiana.
Um,
so that's what Enron got in the business of doing.
And if you look at it the first 12 months,
there's a very broad liquid market,
whether it's done by the commodity exchanges or competing traders,
everyone,
very clear forward market,
everyone can see this.
And,
and if you're looking at taking positions as an Enron to the extent they relate
to widely traded commodities for the F in short periods of time going into the
future,
it's very obvious what you have.
You can tell whether you're making money every day by what happens to the
commodity relative to the risk positions you've put yourself in.
And that's if Enron had stayed with this type of situation,
they wouldn't have made a lot of apparent money,
but they'd be alive today.
It's a tough business.
It's a low margin business,
but you can make a lot of money in it if you stick to your knitting.
But if you want to make a lot of money very quickly,
you start looking at other approaches.
And
if you sort of look at,
and this is for a trading company,
a,
you know,
and manufacturing companies have different,
different types of situations,
but you start with the lowest risk type of asset and that'd be cash,
you know,
uh,
presumably barely highly,
highly rated short term loans,
uh,
to,
to uh,
uh,
the best types of corporations or ideally the u s government.
That's great.
But that's a very low,
low return asset.
Marketable securities,
still very liquid,
but you're starting to increase the volatility of the,
of the returns and you can make more money here,
but it's another place where,
um,
you,
you have to,
you really have to have an information advantage.
What we're doing is we're just sending,
we're going from things that are easily valued to more and more difficult
exchange traded derivatives.
That's the type of thing I was talking about where you have a forward what's
called a forward market where people can sell or buy a commodities for very
clear prices and and it's,
and it's very well known what exactly the market is.
Although at the farther you go out on the the forward market,
the less liquid it is.
So we're even here,
we're starting to to get to a situation where I know that I've committed to say
if I'm an Enron,
I've committed to buy the equivalent of a million barrels of oil a year out.
Well how do you value that is one you get one value.
If you're,
if you're saying,
well I'm going to liquidate it and other value if,
if you're saying how much would someone pay for it?
So even there you're starting to have divergences in terms of how you look at
value,
which can be exploited.
Then we started going as we get down to further down the line in terms of the
levels of certainty.
You have certain types of derivatives like options,
which might instead of being a year out might be five years out.
So people can take the sorts of algorithms,
uh,
useful in inferring or infer the algorithm from the exact existing trading of
short term options,
apply them to long term options and you get a value which is plausible.
So it's based upon clear,
clear market inputs.
But a result which is not self evident because there is no clear trading market.
Finally,
and this is what Enron really got into,
you have unimaginably diverse one off deals.
I'll give you an example.
So a family wishes to buy price protection 20 years out against increases in
yield tuition costs.
And that sounds far fetched.
But that's the sort of thing that Enron was doing that was yell tuition costs,
but taking very exotic situations and then pricing them and,
and so I sort of took an example,
40,
50,
60,
70,000 a year,
years out.
And I'm sure we'd all have a point of view as to how yells tuition is going to
go up.
I mean if it,
if it continues constant,
it goes up probably about inflation plus two or 3% a year.
You'd have a curve,
but it would be very judgmental.
There,
you know,
be,
there'd be some plausibility to it.
But who knows?
And no one else is making a market in this.
So if you're Enron and you and you've staked a huge amount of money,
for example,
on this one trade,
how do they decide how much money they've made in a given year?
Will?
The answer is they use their own curves and if there,
and if they want to make more money,
they just change the assumptions and who's to say they're wrong?
No one.
And that's what it was.
That was,
that was what was happening.
So you have,
you have one off assets,
risk positions,
which were nearly impossible to value,
where the ability to recognize income could be affected with the stroke of a
pen.
And if you're able to recognize income pretty much any way you want,
perversely,
your view of the risk of that type of asset,
it'll slowly start creeping into your mind that it's a low risk asset because it
always has this wonderful profitability that never seems to go down.
Never problematic.
Now.
Normally you'd expect external auditors to question these assumptions,
but Arthur Anderson was making 50 million bucks a year off of Enron.
They going to question anything.
No,
so they could basically create income anytime they want.
The problem though is you end up having an increasing divergence between the
income you're creating and cash can't real cashflow and you're having increasing
divergence between what I might call the intrinsic risk of an asset category and
the risk that you perceive based upon your own manipulative control over
recognition of profits
and that becomes the source of Enron's own downfall is that they
right at the start of each transaction,
they are manipulating the numbers.
It wasn't a top down type of adjustment like Worldcom where basically all the
people at the subsidiary level where we're doing honest things and they're right
at the top,
they started monkeying with the results at Enron,
every single transaction with a gamed to figure out how it could create income,
maximize income,
short term income.
But once you start doing that,
it starts becoming harder and harder and harder to figure out,
well,
where should I be investing my money?
Where should I be placing my,
how should I be adjusting my risk portfolio?
How much debt should I take on?
Because no one has any idea what the risk is and no one has any idea what the
profitability is and that,
that sounds crazy.
That's what it was.
Um,
one of the things,
so you,
so you have so on the asset side of the business where you're,
you're actually taking risks on behalf of the firm and,
and,
and working,
uh,
with,
with outsiders,
uh,
and making money that way.
That was all screwed up.
But they had another problem.
You know,
we,
and we have basically every public company has to provide annually something
called a balance sheet and an income statement and the balance sheet is opposed
to represent the market value.
But in general terms,
the market value of what you own and the obligations you have to outsiders,
which offset some of those assets and give you a net result,
which is what the stock holders,
uh,
really have and the w in the firm.
So you might have $1,000 worth of assets,
you might have debt longterm debt.
Just,
it could be a mortgage to someone,
a $500 you subtract that and you get stock holders equity cause stockholders on
the residual when,
when,
when a firm is liquidate if $500.
So assets always by definition equal to sum of debt of liabilities and
stockholders' equity.
But you may say,
well if you're in Ron,
well I don't want to show all that debt
what you can do.
And I think the techniques would take too long today.
I mean I wasn't set up to go through the techniques I can if people really want,
but it'd be have to be another day.
Basically the accounting rules
like the Internal Revenue Code have a series of precise uh,
procedures,
criteria tests for determining how accounting will work.
The problem with that is that if you are really smart,
you can figure out how to end up with the economic equivalent of a given a
treatment,
but have it appear just the way you want in the account.
So right here I could take this debt and I could move it and associated assets,
$500 out of each column.
And I ended up with $500 of assets at $500 a stockholder's equity smaller firm
to be sure but no debt.
So there are techniques which exploit loopholes so that something that is an
economic terms of debt suddenly disappears or that,
um,
if,
if I want to be able to sell assets to myself,
I can create an alter ego,
something that looks a little bit like an independent company but isn't,
I couldn't recognize gain on the sale even though I'm really selling it to
myself.
And that's because the loopholes and the accounting allow you to achieve form
over substance.
To break the code though,
you have to have a complacent auditor.
And in the case of,
of Arthur Anderson,
over half of their services weren't even auditing services.
There were consulting services,
so they are completely bought off.
Uh,
and you also have to have,
well,
okay,
so
the way the system worked when I started in finance,
you had people who have high,
who were the,
you might call them this sort of the,
the trust gatekeepers.
They would have included a major accounting firm,
high quality law firm,
high quality board of directors.
But the problem is that Tim is that very often the reality,
okay,
of the A,
or put it another way,
the perception of reputation and trust and quality
lags the reality.
So in other words,
if you want to make a lot of money in a short period of time,
you take a firm that has existing good reputation and the you use that
reputation to be able to generate high profits in the short term.
The way you do that as you say,
ah,
AH,
Arthur Anderson,
well,
the high quality firms,
so I don't have to worry about a funny stuff and the accounting,
I don't have to worry if I'm a reader of those financial statements and
investor,
I don't have to worry about whether they're basically disguising debt or whether
they are basically,
uh,
you know,
creating their own earnings out of thin air.
Because Arthur Anderson is a high quality firm,
so generations of people could have built up the reputation of a firm.
But maintaining a reputation,
like maintaining a building requires a lot of ongoing investment.
And if you really want to get a lot of cashflow in a short period of time,
you just let it start to disintegrate.
But people won't notice what's really going on for a long period of time.
And while,
and while you're fooling them,
you,
if you're Arthur Andersen and run one of their clients can make a lot of money
because this is easy money.
This is easy cause cause basically you don't have to create value.
You merely have to engage in an exchange with another member of a capitalist
society who thinks they're informed but isn't.
That's I mean when we think about how capitalism creates value to my way of
thinking,
it's part,
it's a series of informed and voluntary exchanges.
Yeah.
But what does it mean to be informed?
One of the problems with,
with,
you know,
capitalism as exists and not as I read the,
some of these crazy economists is that almost no one is true rational economic
man.
It would probably be a few geniuses that are,
but most people don't have the time.
Don't have the intellect or don't have the cynicism to understand what they're
up against.
So they say,
well,
a good firm,
I don't have to worry about it.
Well the answer is you do have to worry about it.
And that's one of,
that's why my view,
this all came a cropper and the last 10 or 20 years is that the self imposed
restrictions,
which limited short term self interest kept the whole system stable for many
decades.
But once people started to say,
well,
I don't have to worry about ethics,
I mean that's,
I just have to worry about being a rational and realizing my own goals.
Well the answer at that point is the whole system starts to go,
and this is a perfect example because these are people that people are getting
engaged in this sort of deception,
did not have any ethics and would actually view ethics is laughable.
That's really important to realize what people are up against.
And that is their view is if they're creating economic efficiency,
even though they lost side of that too.
Who Cares about ethics?
Ethics is another constraint of a little man.
Um,
so,
hi.
So let's just make sure you link this to,
to,
uh,
off balance sheet accounts.
Did you see the connection there?
The techniques?
Are there techniques or are are
they're intricate.
I was going to bring a piece of paper and have a xerox,
um,
but it's,
it's a diagram of a,
of a,
uh,
transaction among eight different entities involving,
probably 1,015 hundred pages of documents to be able to,
uh,
exploit every loophole possible to create an alter ego entity,
which you control what,
what looks independent enough to be able to shuffle off,
uh,
maybe a billion dollars worth of debt,
billion dollars worth of assets.
Um,
I didn't,
you know,
it's one of these things where,
here's the problem
in modern finance,
one of the tools of the trade is obfuscation.
The transactions are meant to be
mind bogglingly complex.
So lesser people,
lesser intellects,
who rely on reputation to simplify their lives will fall for it.
They'll say,
I don't understand this stuff,
but you know,
I know,
I know that guy on the board and he's a quality guy.
The I,
but the problem then is,
well,
how do you know?
Well,
I've asked Joe.
Joseph is a quality guy.
How's he know?
How can you ultimately investigate all these things?
Well,
the answer is you don't have the time and you may not have the intellect and you
certainly don't have the money to be able to hire people to do that's,
that's how you can start to gain this whole system because there are a lot of
people who expected the old rules of reputation and quality,
which were developed after the 1929 crash as part of an overall change in our
system still prevailed,
but they didn't because basically everyone started being alone and into this
strange sort of idea that markets are perfect and and rash and rational people
will always come up with the most economically beneficial solution.
I agree with that.
If in fact there's some,
there's some limits because the fact is when I think of capitalism creating
value,
I think of it getting around constraints,
but those constraints,
what types of constraints,
the constraints are physical constraints or maybe legal constraints where the
law really is sort of a of a dead letter or a or bad idea.
But like creating the wiggle,
you know,
you have getting around some of the constraints of gravity and creating,
writing,
being,
getting around other constraints.
I mean those are,
those in my way of thinking are very beneficial ways of solving PR,
problem solving.
But the other constraints that people have started to view as
just a minor problem for lesser people are ethical constraints.
So there's an intersection between a sheer complexity and ethical relaxation.
We had it a year ago when things got really ugly.
Steve Schwarzman put together a little round table,
which I attended in New York and Nancy Ferrets Smith made the most interesting
point,
which is is the one you just pay that if,
uh,
if there are asset categories which are so intricate that nobody has really
worked through,
nobody has really worked through,
uh,
all the mechanics of the thing in a way that allows them to understand the
impact of all of the variables in the system.
Then,
um,
uh,
the,
all the sort of market mechanisms which enforce a degree of rationality are
disconnected from the instrument.
Yes,
I agree that there's no [inaudible] if you had,
if you had accountants and boards of directors who in effect did not give
traders the benefit of the doubt,
probably be okay.
But the fact is most people will give the benefit of the doubt to the people
that you smarter.
And that is,
that's a road to extinction,
right?
That is the road to extinction.
Um,
let's talk about the road to Houston.
you,
the book,
uh,
smartest in the room where you are referred to it one point as the fly in the
ointment from and Rod's point of view.
Um,
the most conspicuous characters there are a lay showing and fast out scaling.
Fast out.
Uh,
tell us a little bit about those.
Well,
um,
lay was someone who always operated from 30,000 feet and a big picture guy
super,
you know,
all about strategy.
Uh,
um,
never got into the operating the tails.
Never really wanted to know anything.
If you produced consistent results,
there were absolutely no questions asked.
Um,
and he didn't want to know decent guy in your impression
he was at least as nice as most people I met.
Yeah.
Uh,
how,
how did it nice and decent connect in your mind?
Not at all,
but,
okay.
So he was decent,
decent,
you know,
I mean,
it's okay to hit her personally.
Interpersonally.
He was,
he was not abrasive.
That's one good.
Okay.
And,
um,
so,
uh,
and scaling,
was the,
uh,
was,
was the genius,
a true genius.
Um,
Ooh,
uh,
spanned a span,
a huge range of,
of intellectual,
um,
expertise is,
uh,
there are a lot of people,
a lot of people in life who can only look at the details but are very good at
details.
And there are other people who seem only to be able to grasp the big picture but
then cannot convert it into actual specifics of action.
And scaling was able to move seamlessly from the most detailed aspects of each
transaction to the broadest reach of,
of,
of corporate vision in a way.
I've never seen it before.
He,
uh,
very,
very skilled.
So he was quite literally the smartest guy in the room.
Yes,
I think he was.
Uh,
and as for fast out,
Arthur Anderson has been killed off,
so one cannot,
um,
with one can,
with legal,
without legal risk,
say whatever you want about Arthur Anderson.
Uh,
there are others that,
that,
uh,
um,
there was another party that I'll leave it as the elephant in the room,
uh,
that,
um,
that helped fast.
Now,
let's just say that the professionals who should have been showing some small
degree of allegiance to the shareholders instead of helped avast out,
concoct all these,
uh,
gnarly schemes because he himself was completely unable to do so.
He was just someone who was a,
um,
hm.
Like Rosencrantz and Guildenstern and one of the indifferent children of the
earth.
Uh,
so he was not appear upscaling?
No,
no.
He's a jokester.
He was a joke.
He was a foil.
All he was,
he was just,
you had to have somebody that,
that was basically in there in addition to the professionals from the outside.
And he was there,
but he didn't
so fast out gets possession on both sides of many transactions.
And if,
uh,
and they talk their way through the obvious conflict of interest by claiming his
special expertise justifies the role.
Right.
Then only able to get deals done much more quickly because he knows the assets
so well.
Right.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Now.
So they waived the corporate conflict of interest policy in his case.
Now if scaling and delay had been able to program you
entirely as they wished,
would your role have been analogous to fast rope?
Sure,
sure.
Scaling is scaling asked me to in effect to be fast style.
Um,
um,
when I started at the APP and I just said no,
I was hired to hire it to be CFO,
VP and that's all I'm going to do.
Okay.
So let's talk,
let's talk about the early days when you're in the role of CFO at p.
How does,
what,
what's the,
what's it like when you get up in the morning and go to work and the phone range
and you're off off the well,
great.
So Epp was 51% owned by Enron,
49% by the public.
Um,
and
the,
uh,
while I was the CFO and then later president of Vpp,
the CEO and chairman of the board was,
um,
uh,
rod gray who was a,
an executive at Enron,
uh,
and,
and the parent and who made most of his money from the parent.
And so,
uh,
what,
what happened is that rob rod would come up with some new scheme for
and Ron to be able to dump some expenses on the minority on Etp,
but really I wasn't concerned about Enron is concerned about the minority
shareholders,
minority shareholders,
which was not the first to pay,
uh,
in view.
Um,
and um,
um,
maybe once a week he would come up with some new scheme and maybe,
you know,
over the first six months,
probably total of 50 or $75 million worth of,
of,
of schemes that,
that,
you know,
we just got to keep shooting down.
Uh,
and of course once he did that,
uh,
every time Enron and wanted to sell us a project,
the process being so tainted,
we had to,
uh,
trade very hard because,
um,
in effect I was trading with my own boss.
What risks did you feel yourself exposed to in that situation?
Well,
I didn't,
I didn't worry about,
uh,
I didn't worry about legal risks,
um,
because I was doing the right thing.
I just assumed I had no career.
I was going to have no career.
But on the other hand,
I know there's a little company,
uh,
and uh,
I had helped father this little company that,
that Ron was sort of trying to tear apart.
And so I was,
I would be God damned if they were going to get away with it until they finally,
uh,
um,
announced they were taking away my accounting staff and then they were going to
bill me for the cost,
but have them report the skillings group.
And that's convenient.
That's a very convenient so that at that point that general counsel and the
controller and aisle resign.
So if,
you know,
by the way,
uh,
own,
the only disclosure of a resignation was mine.
They never disclosed the fact that general counsel were designed or the
controller resigned.
The person who replaced me,
um,
ultimately indicted.
I'm not sure whether she was sent to jail.
Indicted paid a big fine,
and I think turned state's evidence there was what war?
Sentencing to prison.
I know.
I saw it.
I thought it was all over it.
Uh,
no,
spinnaker exploration was the next chapter for you by,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
um,
I um,
helped started spinnaker,
uh,
the year after I got fired or actually that my position I was fire,
their position is I quit and run.
Um,
and um,
uh,
it was a,
justice Enron was based on making money off of false information.
Spinnaker was an attempt to make money off of good information and it's a
completely different ways of playing information.
It was the capsule of the business model for state was say,
uh,
the base,
it was engaged in exploration for oil mostly gas and the Gulf of Mexico.
Uh,
with the basic strategic point of view that most,
uh,
most independent oil and gas companies,
whether it's at the overconfidence of their CEOs or macho man mentality,
systematic under value information and would rather dry drill 10 dry holes,
then,
you know,
spend 10% of the money buying a good dataset.
So we got the best data we could seismic data,
which,
which allows you probable inferences about the,
about the structures underneath the earth and sometimes,
uh,
some direct insight into whether gas is around.
Anyway,
we bought a lot of seismic data,
spend a lot of time with processing and spent a lot of time,
um,
making sure we had the,
the best,
uh,
exploration group we could find and,
um,
went into business on that basis.
Uh,
and,
uh,
consistent with our view that information is key.
Not only do we try to get the best external information,
oh,
we also made sure that internally there was a free flow of information so that,
uh,
for example,
every Monday we had a meeting with all the employees where everything was up for
discussion.
There were no questions,
Bard and all the answers where candidate on the basis that it doesn't do any
good to have great external information if the internal flows are not good and
if,
and the internal flows won't be good unless you truly care about what employees
think.
And spinnaker was actually a quite,
was,
it is a quite spectacular that,
well,
I live in spot by Nordisk hydro a couple of years ago,
uh,
what it was,
it was a multibillion dollar company,
certainly when it was bought and it was started at a $50 million.
Um,
a venture capital deal to start.
So,
uh,
spinnaker,
you,
I've heard you say it's been occur was the inverse of every decision,
rule competent and Ron,
whenever we weren't sure what to do,
what you thought,
what would end run do?
I did the reverse.
Uh,
well that's,
let's finish.
We've got,
we've got about 90 seconds.
Uh,
let's finish with,
uh,
chip it.
Jim is a scholar of the Old Testament at the Yale divinity school scholars,
a little strong.
I don't know many people who have read as many sources on arcane aspects of the
Old Testament as you,
I think you're pretty,
pretty serious.
That's why I was in project finance.
It was said,
all right.
You know,
are we all
MMM.
Is American capitalism in a state of advanced moral and ethical or
not necessarily?
If people can grasp the requirements,
the need for,
for ethics,
just to keep the system going.
If people don't come to grips with that,
I think it's just going to get worse and worse.
Okay.
There,
there's a big point there.
It's thick,
thick.
Now back to a Smith's invisible hand,
uh,
and to Hayak and the creative powers of a free society.
Uh,
all that thinking
has built into it at the very most basic level,
an assumption about a truth telling an access to broadly correct information.
And every single,
uh,
every single tenant of the,
tradition,
which runs from Adam Smith through modern economics,
uh,
is founded on them.
And for Smith,
the ethical side of it was explicit with the theory of moral sentiments.
The way economics is taught and the way business management is taught,
the emphasis on an ethical commitment to truth has been somewhat subversion.
It doesn't have the central status,
uh,
for us,
intellectually that it did for a Smith's a generation.
I think that's a fair statement.
Uh,
but,
uh,
Jim,
this has been,
uh,
as it always is a very illuminating and even inspiring.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].